You are listening to radiolab radio, w.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. R.
Who's The gentlemen we're on the air with? Not, oh,
there's going to be two of us. So one of them his name Jab, that's not me.
His name is Jad like his parents call him his Jad. Jad ? but it's Jad really?
Had they been drinking? No, they live in eas. Oh, sorry.
So, uh, we're going to begin the show with this delightful duo. I'm Julie.
Julie Moss. I'm Wendy, Wendy Ingram. Hi Julia. Hi Wendy. Hi. Jad.
They've been friends for a really long time.
I remember that one time you bought all that. Everything in a tube.
They both like to travel.
They both like to shop and they both like to run really long distances until
they collapsed, usually in front of millions of people. Now, Wendy,
Wendy was a classic athlete from day one who was apparently born this way.
Her mother tells me how she had to channel her energy into sports.
I always considered myself a science project.
What do you mean we, we'd been created. We have the hand speed.
We have a mind, we have lungs, we have a heart. Let's see what it can do.
Wendy were very opposite in that respect. Julie,
Julie is an entirely different story and we're going to tell you that story in
just a moment. But first we should say this is radio lab. I'm Chad Apple,
I'm rob and I'm Robert Krulwich. The topic today is limits,
limits of the body,
rest right there in the limits of the brain and finally the limits of what we
can know about everything.
Julie,
how did you get interested in this race that you're about to tell us about?
Was it like a, like an impulse or something? Well, no,
it was a requirement to graduate. I had, I had to do a,
it's called a senior senior project.
I went to cal poly San Luis Obispo in California and I, I was a PE major,
which now I think this is, yeah, and I that was just by default.
I was a California surfer girl.
I started surfing at 14 but I needed a senior project and there I was in um,
1981. Yeah,
watching TV instead of studying. Then
[inaudible] comes ABC wild girls
is brought to you by Anheuser voice
from Hawaii and I watched it and it just sucked me in.
This must have been like really early ironman. Oh yeah.
I think it was the fourth one and I thought it's in Hawaii. It's great.
I know my mom will pay for it because this,
I have to do this project for school and so I started doing research on it and
this, just so we know this is you, you, you swim, you bike, you run.
That's the order. You swim 2.4 miles,
you ride 112 miles and then you run a marathon. So it was,
wait a second though,
that seems like a major decision to want to go 140 I mean were you at triathlete
type person at that point in your life? Had you ran a marathon before?
It was conceptual. Those were just the distances. Those were numbers.
That wasn't reality.
It was just you were in Hawaii by the time I got off the plane to do the iron
man,
I still hadn't completed the total distance that I need to do on the bike or the
swam. Oh my gosh. Wow. But I wasn't going over there to be competitive.
I was going over there to do this event, have fun in Hawaiian,
then I'll write up some sort of bogus, you know,
physiological consequences or something. But I really,
I thought I was taking the easy way out.
When you got off the bus or you walked into the room where the other ones were,
did you suddenly think, oh yeah. I mean, people were taking it very seriously.
People had coordinated outfits and I thought,
I'm feeling a little like, um, the country mouse, you know? So I,
I think when race day rolled around, it was,
it was sort of my day to get through and never do again. I mean,
that was really, this is a onetime thing. So let's see. Shall we run the race?
Yeah. So, okay, let's just,
you do the first two legs to swimming and then the biking.
I'm doing really well. You see me on the bike. I'm riding along.
I mean from the old coverage of ABC. I'm smiling at the camera.
I'm certainly not in an aerodynamic position.
Why would you want to be all crouched over when you keep the sitting up smiling?
That was your beauty queen too. I was doing parade waves.
I really was loving the attention and um,
I had a snickers bar early on the bike ride and I keep thinking if I'd only
eaten that snickers bar instead of throwing it away,
ABC came up on a camera on there.
I was trying to open this melted snickers bar with my teeth and all of a sudden
there's a camera and it's like, oh my gosh,
I don't want to be messy on national TV. So I ditched this,
this beautiful snickers bar and you know, yeah, yeah.
Okay. Skipping to the third leg of the race. Julie's through the swim.
She's through the 112 mile bike ride onto the marathon.
I came off the bike, uh, they told me there's a woman ahead of you at a,
she was a top notch cyclist. Oh. So you were in second place? Yeah. Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa. I was doing really well.
And I started on the run and the one gal who had had a great bike ride had a,
an Achilles injury and sure enough, five, I think about eight miles or so,
I caught her and there I am in the lead. Wow.
And all of a sudden it was a little, um, things started to shift.
Um, I'm, I'm good at something
and somebody trying to take it away from me.
And that was the woman who was in second place, Kathleen McCartney.
And even though she was a mile away,
it felt like she was breathing down my neck and trying to take something that
now I was becoming very attached to.
I was also starting to fall apart physically. What were those early signs?
I'm cramping and a feeling that you weren't digesting your food,
that everything was sort of sitting there, sloshing around Wendy's laughing.
If she's good, this is serious moment and she's laughing about
mini case. Finally,
Julie makes it to the last little advt stretch of the race. Probably about, oh,
about 400 meters from the finish and she's still in first place. Julie,
let's do this. I'm actually, as we're talking, I'm watching you on a Youtube,
oh stinker. But I joined to take me into your head
these final moments cause it's, it's just like,
it's unwatchable but you can't turn away. Yeah, it's a train wreck.
So I'm looking at you now and you're running and it's dark as people like on
both sides cheering you until you're running and then you're slowing down
and you really slowing down and you're looking a little bit like you're on
stilts and then great here.
Your legs give out. They give out.
And I couldn't get back up.
I mean I thought get up and my legs wouldn't work.
[inaudible].
So I actually, I sort of laid there on the ground and um,
I figured out if I put my arms in front of me and leaned on my arms,
they would sort of form like a tripod and I could sort of lean on my arms,
can kind of got one leg up and one leg up and,
and kind of staggered to a walk and started walking again.
All right, now you're walking again, but you're like drunk monkey. Yeah.
Really wobbly. Yeah. No.
All this time your conscious that number two is getting closer and closer.
Are you, are you, are you conscious of her at all? Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
I had to keep finding a way to keep going and my thought was this is mine.
Oh, you just fell again. Oh yeah, yeah.
See this is the one that gets me right here.
You fall down and it's in your arms. Go back. It's like you're dying. Yeah.
And um,
[inaudible]
as I was putting one hand in front of the other, I saw this,
this pair of tennis go by and a these legs and I thought that's her.
She's gone by me
and it was just, I just thought I quit.
I just thought, I can't say it on national public radio, but effort,
effort and all of a sudden
there's this voice that just said, get up, get up,
just keep moving forward.
I could see the finish line about 10 feet in front of me and I thought Getta I
cannot, I can't get up again. I really, I'd get up, do not think like I've,
I've sort of worn out that tactic. Get up, but I can crawl,
I crawl. And so here I am coming along and, and the TV,
camera lights are blinding me and no one's helping her.
My life was going to be different. I mean I felt my life changing.
I made a deal with myself. A deal was struck and I don't care if it hurts,
I don't care if it's messy, I don't care how it looks. I would finish,
I would finish
[inaudible]
so Julie Moss crawls the last 10 feet of the race, literally an inch at a time.
that whole time the cameras are on her and they capture everything.
[inaudible]
and I mean everything. Yeah. I, um,
I pooped my pants on national TV. It doesn't get more shameful.
The firm that Wendy teases me all the time, you know,
you were chocolate mess from war, you know, one way or the other.
You can get up here,
do this next thing. But it was, it was a,
it was a pivotal moment in my life and to the stage. Julie says,
the person she is now,
it all began with that voice that, uh,
that dye hadn't ever called upon that just said, keep moving forward. Well,
that's the thing that gets to me is like, it didn't say to you, you can't, it,
it actually said exactly the opposite. I isn't that cool.
I would have thought it would have said, stop. Come on down.
I don't, that's true.
Ego. That's your ego that will come in and sabotage your real self.
There is no limit. No, I really believe that. Uh, and I does.
I absolutely do. No, no limit. Nope.
[inaudible] nope. [inaudible] nope.
[inaudible] yeah. Now
let's take seriously what Julian Mazda said. Ah, no limits.
I think she meant to psychologically back that. Yes.
I mean they are obviously limits. If she would, well, yes, they could die.
You could die. Yeah, but short of that,
you would say it is her muscles that are determining the limits. Right, exactly.
And the sale, your muscles sale. Yeah. Let's just question that for a second.
Let me introduce you to it.
His name is a, what's his name? David Jones. His name is David Jones.
Hi. Hi. Matt. Tim.
He's retired physiologist and Metropolitan University and he's got a slight
condition that interferes with his speech, just so you know. Okay. Anyways,
he did a study,
two studies actually that involve bikers and he's on experiments likeness.
He'll have these people ride stationary bikes for really long distances. Yeah.
All the while he'll shoot their muscles full of sugar, like with an Ivy
[inaudible] actioning it extremely high levels of glucose in the blood.
How much this look like a whole energy drinks worth of sugar straight into their
blood. Oh, more than that. [inaudible] several energy drinks. Oh No.
Theoretically,
if it's your muscles that are controlling how far and fast you bike,
you should get this injection and just be like,
I shouldn't be performing miracles. That's fine. But it never works.
It never works. Yeah. The people who,
who have sugar in their muscles do the same as people who don't. That's not,
it doesn't work at all in their difference in performance. Whoa.
Bad News for sugar.
And what it suggests is that our muscles have way less to do with our limits
than we think, which raises the obvious question. What is making the difference?
So now I'm going to tell you about the second study, which I completely like,
find mind blowing. Oh, that's a hard study to summarize, but I'm gonna try.
Okay. You say you with me, with you so far, you haven't started yet by that.
Totally a good place to be. I need your full, uh, participation and interest.
Okay.
So he does a study where he puts a bunch of bikers on bikes and he has them
peddle a lot, is about 40 kilometers, long distance. He's got two groups.
Each group gets an energy drink,
which they sort of have to drink while biking while biking,
except that they don't drink it. The rule is they don't actually drink it.
They just swish it in their mouth and suspension out swish and spit.
That's right. That's what they do. Swish, spit, bike, swish, spit by.
Wouldn't want to be the towel guy in this particular experiment.
Well have scientists with buckets who just stand next to them anymore.
I spent him an apartment. Okay,
so half the people get real energy drink to swish and spit.
Yeah.
Half the people get fake energy drink to swish and spit and I kind of tastes the
same and nobody knows who's getting what the normal line.
So you would think in this scenario that nobody should get any benefit from this
because no one's actually drinking the drink, nothing's getting into the body.
Or let's say like the taste creates a placebo effect.
Well then everybody should get the placebo effect equal.
Everybody should get it. But here's the thing. Only the people who switched,
switched, not drank, but switched the real energy drink got a boost.
Oh, how much of a boost in seven minutes? A couple of minutes. Whoa.
That's a lot. Yeah, a minutes. All right. Just demonstrating. Yeah.
Finishing Snelson last. Yeah, so let me think here. Big.
Don't say anything for a minute. Let me think.
So maybe some thing in the first set of athletes who got the real drink,
something inside the new something.
Here's the big theory. Do you want a little theory of the big one first? Well,
I liked the big theory briefly. Okay. The big one briefly.
There's an idea that's been floating around for a while called the central
governor theory, which has it inside your head.
There's this little circuit which you're starting to see on brain scans.
There's this little circuit that governs your energy supply and when it feels
like you're in danger of running
low, it'll trigger signals paint
to be sent to your body to try and get you to rest.
Now with scientists are finding is that this governor circuit is really
conservative.
It'll send you a pain to try and get you to stop way before you are out of
juice. So with your a fuel tank, they would flash e e for empty,
but you got a quarter tank left. So what might be happening with these bikes
curse is it the sugar is landing on their tongue,
the tongue sees the sugar, sends a message to the brain.
The governors sees this message and says, Oh, if we're about to get some energy,
then it's okay for you to spend some energy and let me just give you some from
my secret stash over here. And so you feel a boost.
[inaudible] the conjecture here is you have a reservoir of extra stuff,
but it is so deeply disguised that you can't even know that it's there.
And to skip to the punchline, when you
feel tired, Mr k [inaudible] not just tired.
When you are dead spent. Well you are spent. Yeah,
which does not feel like a subjective thing at all.
That feels like an objective reality. You are done. Well in fact,
at that moment, maybe you're not.
Maybe you're just feeling the effects of that little governor lying to you.
Oh, which raises the question, what if you could live back to her
[inaudible]
then how far could you go? So with all that in mind,
I'm going to kick it up a notch.
Let me tell you about this competition called the ride across America.
It should really be called the ride into the hell fire depths of despair,
but we're going to call it a the ride across quite the zing that the sponsor
wanted. Brian [inaudible] Wrigley's spirit with go.
We heard about this first from a reporter named Daniel Coyle.
So what is the right across America?
It is basically, it's an insane event. You,
you'd get on a bike in California and you bike across the country, 3000 miles,
the equivalent of four Mount Everest.
And they don't sleep at all. No. They will sleep.
They'll sleep a an hour a day, two hours a day.
Hour a day. Yeah. So if, if this is a 10 day race,
they will sleep for 10 hours over the full length of the race. Yeah.
It's a race that is designed to reveal what human limits are.
Who Does it? Can you describe the kinds of people who are attracted to this? No,
I think they come from all walks of life. They come from all over the globe.
It's a really interesting cross section. We actually got curious about this.
So we sent our producer, Lulu Miller to track down a few of these guys.
Two guys. Who'd you find? Well, the first one? Yes.
His name is Patrick Patrick [inaudible]. I'm 47 years old from France. He's the
rookie. Had you done any kind of long distance cycling before? No. No,
not at all. He's actually a scientist. [inaudible] yeah, got a wife. Two kids.
Okay. And then we've got the champion. Okay. A hell of you right here.
So this is Uri Robeck.
He's won this thing four times and on the back he's a killer.
My body, it's, I can go.
So in the rain or cold or the heat job and see the soldier implied by a
Slovenian army. What else? What would you like to know? Okay,
2005 wow.
This start with [inaudible] in San Diego. Touch name
like 20 people or a hundred people.
20 private things to the tape you're getting right now is actual footage from
that deck? Not Backdrop. Turned out the year he did it,
there was actually a film crew.
They're following every single ride and so I was really scared and scared that
him not Uri though. No, he's just in front of Patrick. I really,
uh, I've seen English. Uh, I'm leery shoring myself.
[inaudible]
then the racism, it's easy. You just start your engine and go.
For me and seaside, they didn't know what to expect.
I was very consultative.
I have to back up the back
14 states, 3000 miles to go. They don't go very fast.
They'll cross the country going about 13, 14 miles an hour,
which any 11 year old couldn't ride for a Taco. The difference
is that they just told stop seven hours later.
California desert, it's really hot.
My Watch says 109 degrees. We're in the shade and the car.
Steve Toady,
the camera guy following Patrick in a van hydros out here climbing a hill.
I've never experienced this kind of temperature. You have [inaudible] 10 finite,
then 150 miles later,
Arizona running hills since it
200 300 million.
Then the sun is rising for
500 UTA, it's 10 very hot.
Okay. Correct.
The mountains, the big mountains, you're using the lead,
he's just crested the top of the 12 mile climb.
It was during the middle of the night. It was just raining,
heavy rain and he begins to coast downward sanding without battling
and after two kilometers I was completely frozen,
shaking like I was electric in your bet is like a hamburger. Yeah.
I mean it's all red. You don't have any skin at all.
I mean the bike is the most efficient machine for creating suffering ever.
And the pressures on your hands, the pressure is on your neck.
This is this British guy named Chris Hopkinson.
Halfway through the race and his neck just given out.
People who's next have given out. We'll take duct tape
and literally tie their heads up. They'll,
they'll put a quarter to the back of their helmet and then pin it,
say to their belt, Jesus, God. So that they can look, cause they're,
they can no longer hold their heads up.
The paint is like waves,
you know, and I don't know why he's dead, but it is,
it's like waste. It's calming. Candy's going.
[inaudible] he's going to lose assuming that the central governor circuits
inside the heads of all these writers are creating those waves of pain.
How do they soldier on? How do they ignore it? Well, I ask them that and
they each sort of have different techniques. So Patrick
just start shouting back at it literally. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
And Uri, well he gets his crew to come up alongside him and Blair
[inaudible] y'all go to speakers? Yeah.
Is that what we're hearing? It is. This is him on his bike during the race.
Singing along
works for awhile, but then they hit the halfway point.
I don't know if you've been to, Ken says, I don't know. It's awful.
Scenery gets really monotonous and you don't have any sightseeing,
nothing more than that.
They've gone over a thousand miles without sleeping basically.
Then that's where we see the sort of really interesting stuff start to happen.
It's here that we can catch a glimpse of the hidden potential of the human body.
If you've done everything, if you've handled the heat and hydration,
if your infrastructure is solid, all the stress goes to the last point,
which is the mind it,
Ken's very suddenly twas Doc.
I were in a forest and very quickly the environment got very um,
accuracy. He said he saw shadows running across the road.
It looked like the trees were trying to reach out to get him.
I was starting to have nightmares, but I was awake.
These kinds of hallucinations are just a fact of the race.
People seeing secret code in the cracks of the road,
riders jumping off their bikes to square off and fight mailboxes,
and it's what breaks a lot of people. Strangely,
these kinds of hallucinations might be the very key to Yuri's.
I saw everything.
I mean a lot of like monsters like zombies,
he's gonna attack, you know, and why would that help him? Well, me,
it was really think about why the central governor's in place,
the system that's designed to always keep an emergency stash of energy there for
you. Should you ever need it.
So those feelings of pain are really just a way of safeguarding that last little
stash of energy that you could use if you absolutely had to. Yeah.
Like if your life was on the line or something, that's right.
But what if you are convinced and therefore your central governor was convinced
that your life really was on the line
that year when you got to Ohio, he,
he hallucinated that there were Lucia hot dean's or Afghan horsemen chasing him.
Yeah, with a gun or be the shot gun. And I said to two bikers to your face,
they had a shooting guard. Come on, come on to something.
We are soldiers did something to this idea or attack.
The interesting thing about that is that is the way in which his team sees him
hallucinating. Lose your Heidi and their reaction is, oh yeah,
we see them to go on you. Are you mind? We might escape. Why?
Because they're gaining on us. They're getting on it. It's funny. I know,
but for me it was not funny.
They will use his hallucination as as fuel and they make no bones about it.
And when you see that, that's Matiaz planning check Uris, crew chief,
when you see him riding that fast after five, six days almost dying on the bike,
and then suddenly he explodes,
your hair on your arm would go up on your neck would go up. And then, you know,
that's, that's why we are there because it's,
you don't want to miss that moment because this is something out of this world.
[inaudible] says that during the hallucinations, I mean, the pain is gone.
Does it go, does it go away completely? Yeah.
But the tradeoff is that when he watches videos of himself like this punching
mailboxes and throwing his bike into a ditch, he says,
it's actually painful to watch.
You know, it's really tough for me to look in myself in this videos,
in these films. Uh, how do I maybe or is going,
the reality is he's looking at a madman. It's not to me, that's,
that's not me.
Yeah. Let's see. Now I'm thinking like Daniel,
like if madness is the key,
right to tricking your central governor and to giving you access to that,
did that energy,
does that mean that if Robert and I went mad in this particular way that we
would suddenly be really athletic? I mean,
are there actually seriously cases like that? Well,
there was actually in the early 19 hundreds there was a doctor named August beer
who noticed a mental patient making a leap in an asylum and he measured the leap
and it compared rather favorably to the world record at the time. What? Yeah,
and he was one of the early sort of propagators of this governor theory that Oh,
obviously this patient from whom all the sort of governors had been lifted was
capable of, um, a feat of astounding strength.
Absolutely. What happened at the end of the race? Well,
he wins. I want to ram
it. 17 and what about that?
Well, let's rewind a couple of days.
He's just crossed the halfway point Mount Vernon, Kansas,
and he decides to hop off his bike, take a quick break, and he's in the van.
He checks his email just to give me some motivation and he sees an email from
one of his friends.
He said, we're so sad that, uh, the Dr Breedlove accident,
Patrick had no idea
what this guy was talking about,
but it appeared to suggest that one of the 25 riders,
a guy named Dr Bob Breedlove,
I had just been hurt. And so I asked one of my crew member, uh,
what happened was Dr Breedlove and he said, well,
he got an accident and he died
on the rate during the race. Yeah.
And so when he's, when he's, when he told me this, I mean,
immediately I was, I was, I mean, I was, I was, I mean that, I mean,
nothing is shocked, but I was done. I understand. Patrick.
I feel bad too, obviously.
And so it has happened, Steve, today, the commandment tried to push me both.
It would be pointless to, to stop here where you have a wide shoulder,
a van right behind you, who's going to, to [inaudible] and to, oh,
well, sorry. But a petri just fall down the road.
And so he's hospitalized or, or even even, even worst.
I have kids and a voice I went to, I went to found this fish.
I understand Patrick put how far the next time station. Why don't we go there?
[inaudible] dead. I don't want to continue that.
That's so sad. That's okay. I don't want to continue that. I'm just saying,
let's not throw in the towel just yet. Okay. So after that, I mean, uh,
I started writing again. [inaudible]
but, uh, for them
it was a magical night is very, uh, very well, a beautiful night,
no class, nothing.
And there's always this Cruz cheering him on, trying to pump them up.
Yes. Patrick, can I ask you why you're doing this?
Can I ask you a question or don't you want to talk?
Why are you doing this?
But he's not saying anything back for hours.
[inaudible] around one in the morning, Patrick says, his mind
just goes quiet, completely silent.
Out of that silence, he said he heard a voice that said simply
you'll step step.
So that's what I did. I said, yeah,
I'm done. I'm done.
You asked me a question on here. Remember why? How was it doing that? Yeah.
Because I just went, is this my name?
It physically and mentally and I touched twice this week.
Yesterday morning and this morning I don't want to leave that again and uh,
I quit. That's it.
Huh?
I'm trying to figure out who I would honor more. Yeah.
The winner of the race or the land who insisted on losing.
I'm 40. I've got kids identified more with the guy who stopped. Yeah. Yeah.
But I think also you,
you see the guy who wins and it makes you ask big questions about what's
possible. Yeah. Yeah. Like how do he do that? Yeah.
I don't know that I'd want to be that guy or even hang out with him.
I like the second guy. I know. I'd like the second guy. Bam. What do you think?
I find myself looking at both of them, kind of with my jaw on the floor.
[inaudible]
Daniel Coyle. His latest book is called the talent code
and thanks Lulu. Yeah.
And a huge thanks to Stephen our back who made the film bicycle dreams.
That's where all this footage came from.
[inaudible]
Hey Michael, this is Wendy [inaudible] and I apologize. I have a few that ready.
A lot of fun. And it's part by
Ltps Long Foundation and the National Science Foundation. This is Chili moms.
Radiolab is produced by W N Y, Z and distributed by n p. R.
Hey, I'm Janet. Boom. Right. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab today.
Our topic is limits limits. How far can you take your, your body.
We've done that. We've exhausted that thing, so, so let's go uptown. Yeah,
to the limits of the brain. [inaudible] tackle. Just a piece of that question.
Let's just take a look at memos. Okay. All right, great.
And we're going to do that by telling a story,
a story that we heard from Jonah Lehrer. Yeah. You know,
frequent guest on the show, author of the books, Proust was a neuroscientist.
How we decide the story begins in a small town in the old Soviet Union back in
the 1920s and it's about a newspaper reporter named Mr s,
at least that's what we're going to call him. Yeah.
So Mr Eslan newspaper reporter and one day his boss starts yelling at him
because his boss gives out these assignments,
talks to the whole newsroom and he notices that Mr s never takes notes.
And this drives his boss crazy cause his bosses, you know,
saying all these things they have to report on and Mr Estis never writes down.
And so his boss calls me to his office and says, are you lazy?
Do you not take this job seriously? And Mr s response,
will I just remember it all.
Mm.
And the editor says, come on. And He sorta quinces him. He says,
what did I assign you yesterday? His boss gives them this quiz and sure enough,
he remembers everything. He remembers everything.
The editors had word for word
and the editors thinking, I don't know what's wrong with this guy. I mean,
he's not a great reporter, but he has something queer going on in his head.
So he decides to send him to a famous medical doctor in Moscow,
a r Luria who is Luria the book lawyer.
He's a classical figure is in neuropsychology and in psychology in general.
And who is this host your name? Oh,
her that the Goldberg Abbott Clinical Professor at NYU medical school.
Goldberg, New Loreo lawyer was my mentor. I worked very closely with him.
Not only was he a student of Loris,
Luria gave him a present once basically visible.
This is the book.
This book is one of the great works of early neuroscience. Oh,
so we're going to the right guy. You have an autographed copy by the guy.
It is a beautiful and almost novelistic description of what happened to Mr s
[inaudible] original title was a little book about big Beverly. Yeah.
What is it in Russian [inaudible]. Okay, so Jonah,
this guy, Mr s goes to this psychologist Luria.
Now what does Lauria do with them?
Luria during the book talks about how he wrote random numbers on a blackboard
numbers like one eight, six, four,
three about 50 numbers and asked Mr s to remember them.
Here we are on page 60 as what studied the material of the board for about three
minutes. Slows his eyes, opened them again for a burger. Okay. Done.
And with that, he would really love the series. Precisely six,
six, eight zero.
That's like a superpower. Yeah. And this impresses Larry. He says,
so he takes it up to the next level. Then Larry, uh, gives him, Ya know, this,
this,
this incredible assortment of memory tasks and everything from memorize Dante's
inferno, um, to the whole thing. No,
no. Wow. You're not the whole thing.
Just opening stances and meds that are coming in of [inaudible] near it.
Provide Aroma. Salvo, here's the really weird thing.
Mr [inaudible] does not read Italian month's speak Italian.
He had no idea what he was talking about.
Ideally a smelly and yet the thing he memorizes, he gets him word perfect. Yeah.
And not only that, he was tested 15 years after.
He'd memorize those stances and he's still got it right? Yeah. Oh Man.
I remembered everything. He had everything.
What did you mean by you mean everything? Okay. So if he,
suppose he interviewed you 10 years ago,
he would have remembered the color of your sweater,
whether you held the Mike in the left hand or in the right hand,
you would have remembered everything. I mean, everything.
Larry never talks about a computational limit on Mr s's memory as an experiment.
I soon found myself in the state virgin or utter confusion and they simply had
to admit that the capacity of his baby had low distinct limits.
How can there be no limits?
Cause I'm thinking about the size of a normal head.
It's like 50 centimeters or something in diameter. The brain is three pounds.
It's a very confined little situation. How could there be no limits?
I wish there was a good answer.
Nobody has any idea why it is he had this infinite capability for recall.
Um,
what it does suggest though is that the brain has the capability to store an
incredible amount of stuff. How much stuff though?
How much can you GAM into a human brain? I, I don't,
I don't think anyone knows. I mean, so let's just stop. Let's face,
let's call it quits. No, no, no. And if I forget that, in fact,
let me take you to a competition which investigates that very question.
We're going to change locations from, where were we just now? Russia.
We were in Russia from Russia in 1920s too. You ready for this?
London 2009 here we are at the world memory championships,
the worldwide, the world memory championship. Cause go with me for a sec. Okay.
So we're in a hotel in central London.
The lobby is crowded with the world's best memorizers.
So what was your name yet? People here from like Oman, [inaudible] Raj.
I'm Dr Grantee Manchester. Hello Neil Hawk. Netherlands. Yeah.
Rick Deion even have a team of Chinese girls in the corner doing a cheer.
What are we doing here? Well,
the people here are a little bit like the guy you were describing, Mr s.
They are walking experiments in brain stuffing
the differences. They're perfectly normal human beings.
Could you start by introducing yourself? Yeah. Okay.
Take this guy on benfit or on the reigning world memory champion.
I'm 33 years old and I live in Nottingham.
Then can take a string of numbers that is 1400 numbers long,
random numbers, random numbers, and he can commit it to memory instantly.
He can take a deck of cards and memorize it in 24 seconds.
Wow. Yeah. We've not actually reached, you know,
any kind of upper limit of what it's possible to memorize yet,
but he's still consistently in faith.
So here's what we did. We, we found a guy, oh, I'm a,
my name is Ronnie White and am the 2009 USA memory champion. He's a,
a Navy reservist from Dallas, Texas. And our fact a,
I had to get permission from my unit to come here, but
we followed them around the competition. What's about to happen? Well,
the is about to start, you know, you know,
it's day one to be a fun day because we wanted to know like, how do you do it?
How do you take the limits of a normal brain and completely shattered.
So I walked in the room that day wearing my Michael Phelps tee shirt, you know,
it said USA on the front.
Okay. You don't run rates, preparation time.
The final minutes before you start an event,
you're sitting in your chair and you're just collecting your thoughts.
I put on my military glasses, I got some [inaudible], drew Carey's glasses,
and I put those on to remind me, hey, remain calm. You know,
I wore those all throughout my tour in Afghanistan.
If you're going down a road and, and uh,
you're needing to be on the lookout for ideas, but you're not calm,
you're nervous and jittery, you could die.
Then I'll put on some noise canceling headsets. Then I just close my eyes,
sit in my chair.
Maybe neurons on the ready. They say
that moment. 60 people turnover papers
on these pieces of paper. A numbers six, seven, one,
nothing but numbers in time. Where's numbers? Numbers,
numbers and numbers forever. And what are they doing? Well,
they have to memorize them.
So they just used to seeing all these people staring at pieces of paper. Yeah.
Absolute silence. Heads down.
60 heads down, staring at numbers six, seven. But here's the,
here's the interesting thing in their heads. Three, they're not seeing numbers.
Four instead, those numbers are turning into eight of George Bush.
One Randy Richardson, he's a friend. One 45 a rash. Michael Jordan,
Chuck Norris, Donnie Brasco, two Bush. That was boy George, Joe t,
Martha Stewart, George Michael, Ben Franklin, Chuck Norris,
and Frank Indiana Jones. Five my friend Ronnie King, Todd.
Uh, I have a person assigned to every number from zero to 99, eight.
And then I have a verb assigned to every person from zero to 99.
And then I have a noun assigned to every digit.
So you're just taking the person verbs and objects
and you're putting them all together and they really don't make sense.
What were some of the [inaudible]?
The images? I saw a,
I saw Albert Einstein riding the roller coaster into a bunch of fog.
Five, nine, three, seven, eight, seven. That was one of the images. Um,
I saw a fat Albert cartoon character driving a car.
Eight one, nine, nine. Um, I saw a Victoria's
model, which was one of my favorite pictures.
I saw Victoria's secret models shooting a gun,
uh, stuff like that.
So there seems to be something about turning data into pictures that makes that
data edge. It becomes easier to hold on to. Do you have any idea?
Why do I have any idea why you you but Jonah,
I dunno, I, I would just be purely speculating here,
but the visual cortex has been hugely enhanced in human evolution. It's the,
you know, the rear half of our brain because we know that memories, you know,
there is no memory center of the brain. It's distributed in our sensory areas.
It might make a little sense that given that we've got this huge chunk of visual
cortex that it's easier to store memory there.
Okay. So let me ask you, how did Ron's visual cortex do in the big content?
Ron? Ron didn't actually do so well.
He didn't [inaudible] he was trying to memorize these 12 decks of cards and he
had constructed this whole, like a stack of pictures. But he,
he did them in the wrong order and he screwed it up. He lost,
he lost really badly. Unfortunately. I was shocked. I mean,
I was just shocked that that knocked me out of any passion,
you know, by the way, who didn't lose it?
Remember Mr s the guy we started this conversation with? Yeah, sure.
This is interesting.
It turns out that Mr s also had little pictures and little characters running
around in his mind, but unlike Ron,
he never asked for the picture.
No, he couldn't. You know, even when he wanted not to do it,
he couldn't help but do it anyway. What he was born that way.
He had this tremendous memory without any effort that without an mnemonic
techniques viscerally the point,
you mean his mind made the pictures automatically? Yeah.
Mr S had a condition called synesthesia where your senses get kind of tangled
up, so he heard voices in terms of colors, right? Colors of voices,
textures, smells of words, and his numbers weren't just numbers.
Sometimes he imagines walking through a crowded Moscow street and the numbers
are scattered along the way and so he describes how I'm walking down the street.
There's the number one. This is a proud, well-built bat.
Then I make a right turn onto the side street.
There's the number of tools of high spirit I then I make a left turn.
There's a number three, a gloomy person, y I don't know. Nobody knows.
Nobody knows exactly what accounts for the individual associations of
synesthesia that they just exist,
but they're this extra scaffold for mr s's memory to cling to. Wow.
So he's like Ron, except he's using all his senses to remember numbers. Exactly.
So, um, getting back to the plot, what did, uh, what did he do with his talent?
He became a traveling circus freak basically. Yeah.
[inaudible] like, Whoa, sorry. Mr [inaudible] list. Yeah.
He gave up journalism to perform for just
imagining when something I like, yes.
She had told me, please feel glow. Zig kept the
memory.
[inaudible] a big crowd. He walks onto the stage, he gives them an invitation.
He asked them to shout random members,
58 55
[inaudible] seven 545 5,203. Then after a little while,
the crowd quiets down, Eh,
Mr s would close his eyes and step forward. Then he would remember them all.
This was his [inaudible]
job. Yeah. And it wasn't just numbers by the way. He was thrown weird phrases.
Nonsense sounds, nouns, verbs.
And sometimes you do four shows a day. And the more he did,
the more obvious it became that this business is,
you'd had a downside.
[inaudible]
here's what we're going to finally reach.
Maybe the limits question that we're really examining in this program.
You would hear all these nonsense phrases being thrown at him and they would
build up in his mind and I,
it's important to note this was incredibly frustrating for Mr s.
He had a constant stream of memories pouring into his brain.
He couldn't get any of it out and on top of that, as they piled up,
the memories began to kind of [inaudible]
whoosh together. One will trigger another and then another and then another.
It was the suffocating web of association. The moment he encountered everything,
everything,
even the both the related in his past to that something was immediately evoked
in his bedroom. For example, let's suppose a man in the audience
stands up and you shout out the word
doll for a split second,
Mr s sees a dog which suggests another dog and then another dog.
Every dog he ever saw
and the main suggestions suggested not just that meeting, but the main site.
I other than the minute he knew all the other competitions were a similar look
in me and stood up in, chatted something similar.
She was [inaudible]. She was the news was all kinds of medleys.
Totally unrelated.
Everything in layer one, layer two on top of the other. Oh that's horrible.
I agree. Oh that's what be a bloody nightmare.
The mind isn't just interested in storing information.
It really wants to be able to get meaning out of that information,
out of those memories.
And that actually seems to be turned off to be inhibited by remembering too much
[inaudible].
In other words, there really is a limit in our heads.
It's a different kind of limit, really not the limitless to remember one
number after another, but a precious balance in your head.
If you remembered too much, you will make no sense of the world.
It's weird.
I've never actually thought of making sense of the world as being an act of
negation. Yeah. Do you know what I mean?
It's very much that they kind of make sense.
Cause if you think about like living here in New York City, New York City,
all the people you bump into,
if you remembered every freaking one you would have fun.
Like you wouldn't be able to have a relationship with your wife or your husband
and your child cause they just be lost in this thick crowd in your head.
Just like get him out somehow. That's the balance.
The act forgetting is crucial to create
preciousness. Although I do wish I had a better memory.
It's your day weekend.
This is Chris Callahan from Berkeley,
California and Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation
and by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Janet. Boom. Ron, I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and this next segment began with a simple question.
Seeing as our topics so far has been limits and sure we've done body and we did
the brain. Now we're going to go really big. Yeah. Yeah.
So we called up Steve Strogatz, mathematician at Cornell University,
frequent guest on the show,
and we asked him are there limits to human knowledge? Yeah.
And his answer sent us on a little adventure. Um, the, yeah.
Is there anything that's at the limits of our knowledge is a question that a lot
of us scientists worry about and, and uh,
certainly the 20th century taught us that there are many things that limit our
knowledge. For instance,
that the Heisenberg uncertainty principle in quantum physics showed us that you
can't know the position and momentum of a subatomic particle at the same time.
You just can't do it.
It's not a matter of not having good enough instruments or not being clever
enough. It's just a fundamental barrier that nature puts in your way.
I'm in logic.
Girdle's theorem tells us you can't prove certain things even though they're
true. So there are all kinds of limits,
but those seem a bit remote from everyday experience.
And yet I think there are really important limits on our knowledge that we're
all familiar with.
What I'm thinking of here is our inability to think about big numbers.
Because with your fingers, you've got 10 you know, normally.
So we're good at 10, we're barely good at a hundred.
And once you start getting to thousands, millions, billions and trillions,
w it gets hazier and hazier.
When you hear now about the trillions of dollars in the deficit or whatever it
is, the debt, you know, we don't, that means nothing.
How are you supposed to think about that? Now when you ask,
why can't we understand the common cold? But we can put a person on the moon.
It has to do with large numbers, not just large numbers of numbers. So Steve,
but large numbers of things interacting.
But there are so many genes involved and so many biochemical reactions involved.
Our brains are limited, our memories are very limited. And so, um,
I worry a little bit that,
that we might be approaching the end of our ability to have insight into certain
kinds of questions. What Steve Means by the word insight, there's not like a,
you found the answer. It's like, that's like a feeling,
right? You don't like that. Oh, [inaudible]
get it feeling you get when you really understand the answer. Yeah.
That satisfying feeling that I can see the reasoning and I can actually feel it
in my bones. That's, that's a very pleasurable feeling. But, um,
one that we may not always
be able to enjoy. I mean, you can see the space.
We weren't really quite sure how to feel about this, but then Steve said, yeah,
don't take my word for it. Talk to these guys at work down the hall from me.
You'll see. Yeah, we can, we can go right ahead. Cool.
Can you guys introduce yourself? Tell me who I'm talking to. Yes. So, uh,
my name is Hod Lipson. My name is Michael Schmitt. I am a phd student and uh,
I'm a roboticist and hot and Mike have developed this thing which does make you
wonder if Steve's right. It's a computer. Yes. Actually many,
a whole tower of computers that are all grinding away and performing
calculations.
Actually when you get down to it, it's just a piece of software.
But they've named it the Eureka cause. That's what it's designed to do,
to have you Rica moments. Uh, maybe a, a kind of simpler example.
The story of Eureka begins pretty simply. Think of it with a pendulum. Okay?
The pendulum, just one of these things you see hanging off a grandfather clock,
okay, I've got a regular pendulum's swinging in my mind. Okay?
Swinging left and right now says hod w instead of a string connected to ball,
make it a string, connected to a ball, connected to another string,
connected to another ball, which is basically like a double pendulum.
The cool thing about this is you just put it up, you lift it up and let it go.
And what you'll get says Mike is chaos.
That's really crazy behavior instead of Nice.
And even now you got random,
it's almost impossible to actually try to predict where this thing will move.
So what they did was they got a camera connected it to Eureka and Jesse just had
Eureka Watch this thing, you know, move about crazily.
And then they asked the computer a really simple question,
can you make some kind of sense out of this erratic behavior?
Like is there something in this system that always stays the same?
Tell me what about these panda?
Lomas overtime is not changing because with everything there's gotta be some
kind of logic in there.
So you're looking for a law basically mean you're looking for the law of the
double pendulum. Yes, that's the idea. So Eureka is,
they're watching this pendant that was about 3:00 AM in the lab is basically
spitting out all of these different guesses, formulating hypotheses.
It's getting closer and closer.
And then onto the screen pops this simple Pharma f equals m.
What is f equals? I May.
Is that actually the law that f equals the May is Newton's law of motion,
the Isaac Newton that Sir Isaac to you.
So Basic Law of physics in one of the greatest discoveries in the history of
human thinking.
Uh,
took it about a day, 24 hours.
but the interesting thing is that it came up with this thing without knowing
anything about physics, nothing. That's why we kind of,
we think that this algorithm might be able to find new laws that we don't know
about yet.
In fact, once word got out about Eureka,
that's when the emails start a couple of emails a day to scientists all over the
place who were like, Hey,
do you mind if we borrow your robot for what kinds of stuff?
Um,
anything you can think of from trying to predict behaviors of cows in the herd
to particle physics, to a stock market
and fats. And this is when we get to Steve's point about the limits of insight.
That's when they met this guy.
My name is girl swell girl is a biologist at the University of Texas
Southwestern Medical Center. He got in touch with hod when you said,
I have this amazing data, which is single cell dynamics,
meaning he's got this tiny little thing. So simple bacteria,
really basic and he's been collecting this information on how it works on its
inside. Oh, things go up and down. Certain nutrients increase,
certain nutrients decrease over time. Just like a pen.
A long thing is in a cell. It's like thousands of pendulums.
There's so many part genes turning on and off, thousands and thousands,
tens of thousands of proteins turning on other genes and nutrients going up and
down.
It's this crazy quilt of complicated feedback and you wanted to know inside of
the cell, how are all of these things related. We can measure it all,
we can see things going up and down and all that. But what are the rules?
What are the rules here in this? He says is the problem for biology.
Biology is one of the least well understood systems compared to let's say,
chemistry and physics. They're still lacking the basics. So we said, look,
Mr Robot,
can you tell us what you think are sort of the important principles governing
this organism and maybe detect things that were hidden from us.
So he sent us the data and we analyzed it and uh,
well, OK, let's not let [inaudible] suddenly equation starting,
popping out.
Almost immediately the robot came back to us and said, okay,
here's a set of two equations that describe your data.
Do you remember by any chance what the, what the actual equation was? Not,
not that we'd understand it, but just sort of to hear it said out loud. Yeah,
no, I don't want you don't have my rain man skills develop to that degree yet.
Important thing is that the equation was telling him things like when this
protein goes up,
this other thing always goes down and when that thing goes down,
this gene turns on and does a loop de loop,
and when he went to his cell to check all this out, the equation was right.
These equations matched the data and in fact they explain new data.
These equations could even predict what the cell was about to do,
but hold the champagne. There's just one little problem here.
The formulas checkout, but we don't know what they mean.
You don't know what they mean, right?
Meaning they don't know why these equations work. I why when this goes up,
does that go down? Why? When that goes up, does this go sideways? Why?
I had to first look at this and try to make sense of it. We said like, oh,
okay. I think we understand and we're like, oh, maybe we don't.
We think that we're close to understanding it, but you know,
now we're in this bizarre situation.
We can't even publish it right now because we can't just publish a equation
without explaining it. So in the end,
they're in this awkward position where they've got the answer,
but they don't have
the insights. And I think it's a preview of what's the common science.
The more we turn to computers with these big questions,
the more they'll give us answers that we just don't understand.
We'll be faced with this challenge of having to find ways to get a computer to
explain what it found.
But that will leave us if this really happens in some weird position as
bystanders where we're, we're sort of listening to the oracle,
but not really understanding the answer. Is there going to be a time when we,
we can't cut it anymore. We've had this,
this window in human history when we could not just know things but actually
understand them. That is, you could know why they were true. Not just no,
but to know why. And that's a beautiful moment in human history.
But I feel like it may only be a moment. Well, I don't really see it quite that,
that sort of sad and dramatic because at the end there will be simple principles
to describe even the most complicated of processes.
So you have a bias that prevents you from feeling the kind of despair that Steve
feels in that we were hoping you would feel. Oh, well I'm, I,
I have a positive outlook, but I just wondering about the,
we look what we have discovered.
You'll say when you're an old man with your robot sitting there and address next
to you and the robot will be holding your hand,
but that will be a cold hand and Jad and I will be thinking,
I don't know who's the we here as well. I would say we is sort of knowledge.
I'm just thirsty for understanding and thirsty for knowledge.
Me In the cold hand, holding my hand,
we've accumulated and contributed to the overall understanding of something that
we thought maybe 50 years ago. It wasn't possible.
And that would be something that would make me happy.